[Musique]
le bonsoir à tous mardi 26 mars le 7-8
journal sur tv soixante dix huit pour
revenir sur l'actualité locale bienvenus
si vous nous rejoignez tout de suite les
titres de cette édition est de
dédramatiser le monde médical et
susciter des vocations chez les tout
petits le but de l'hôpital des nounours
une action développée par des étudiants
en médecine de l'ue vs qq qui se tenait
aujourd'hui à bois d'arcy un hôpital
fictive constitué pour soigner des
peluches malades apportées par les
enfants dans exactement deux mois les
français devront élire leurs députés
européens scrutin dont les enjeux sont
souvent mal connus à voisins le
bretonneux le comité local de la
république en marche organisée une
conférence débat sur le sujet ait des
anciens et actuels leurs parlementaires
étaient présents et puis connaissez-vous
la pole la poule faverolles elle a été
servie par le chef du trianon palace à
versailles pour son repas de la fête de
la francophonie une volaille venant d'un
village d'eure-et-loir élevé à la ferme
de la petite aux gars auffargis
reportage et puis nous recevrons
également tout à l'heure christian
etienne du cercle celtique 16 avait
lille organise son festin aux du
printemps c'est ce samedi à trappes l
hôpital des nounours a donc ouvert ses
portes aujourd'hui à bois d'arcy un
hôpital éphémère lancé dans un but
pédagogique par l'association poèmes de
la faculté de médecine de saint quentin
en yvelines un bénéfice pour les
étudiants et les enfants mais aussi pour
leurs enseignants et leurs parents où il
friedrich i et patrick jacques de
dixmude
consultation en nounours au logis
aujourd'hui pour les étudiants en
médecine de saint quentin en yvelines
face à eux deux jeunes patients de 3 à 6
ans qui ont fait le déplacement pour
obtenir des soins pour leurs animaux en
peluche
en fait il est tombé de huy et du coup
il s'est passé des nageoires du coup il
peut plus nager et du coup je me partout
pour s'occuper de nemo et de ses amis la
ferme de la tramblais à bois d'arcy a
donc été transformé en hôpital pour les
prochains jours les étudiants vont
pouvoir apprendre à mieux communiquer
avec les enfants et les enfants vont
dédramatiser le monde médical au cours
d'un véritable parcours de soin de la
salle d'attenté bloc opératoire en
passant par le service radiologie
ils sont assez surprenants parce que
certains ont réponse à tout
il me repousse dans nos retranchements
et puis
ils sont pleins d'imagination c'est
incroyable 38 faculté de médecine
française se prête à l'exercice
chaque année mais c'est en allemagne que
le projet a été initié dès l'an 2000
angleterre pérou japon roumanie se sont
aussi joints à l'opération
en plus on leur offre un petit un petit
nounours pack donc en fait avec un petit
ses toasts coop en plastique enfin tout
un tas de petits goodies des petits
coloriage et tout ça pour se souvenir de
cette journée les enseignants mis à
contribution lors de ces journées feront
le bilan avec les étudiants dans
quelques jours l'occasion de prendre des
nouvelles de leurs patients et de
répondre aux dernières interrogations
des enfants et pour ceux qui
s'inquiéteraient des blessures de nemo
rassurez-vous manon devrait bien prendre
soin de lui et voir le maître des
comprimés chine se chiffre à présent
2000 le nombre de parents pardon au samu
des yvelines le nombre d'appels par an
celui des yvelines pour des tentatives
de suicide elle entraîne mille 500
hospitalisations pour prévenir la
récidive un dispositif va être déployé
dans le département vigilance déjà en
place sur d'autres territoires a été
présentée au centre hospitalier de
versailles pour le piloter une équipe
administrative basée à l'hôpital de
plaisir et une équipe opérationnelle
dans les locaux du samu à versailles
elle est composée de psychiatres et de
vigilance heures qui vont recevoir les
appels les explications au micro de
marylène iapichino c'est un dispositif
de veille des suicidants c'est-à-dire
qui a pour but de rester en contact de
maintenir un lien avec les patients
service d'un sortie d'un service de
soins après une tentative de suicide
notamment dans les premiers mois qui
suivent le geste suicidaire puisqu'on
sait que ce sont des mois à haut risque
de récidive suicidaire et de mortalité
par par suicide
là ce sera un lien par téléphone et par
système de cartes postales et ça permet
de faire diminuer le risque de récidive
en scène
un numéro vert aussi intégré dans
dispositif qui leur permet de nous
rappeler si jamais ils ressentent le
besoin ou qui sont en crise suicidaire
ce qui après nous nous permet de
déclencher les secours immédiatement un
dispositif qui sera donc déployée tout
comme son numéro vert courant avril
dans tout juste deux mois les citoyens
de l'ue ont rendez vous aux urnes pour
les élections européennes à cette
occasion le comité la république en
marge de voisins-le-bretonneux organisé
hier une conférence débat présence
notamment du député yvelinois jean-noël
barrot et aussi de l'ancien député
européen philippe herzog reportage de
patrick jacques de dixmude et dori
léonce mieux comprendre la situation
européenne ainsi que les enjeux du
prochain scrutin
pour cette réunion à voisins le
bretonneux le public était au rendez
vous parmi les intervenants l'ancien
député européen philippe herzog
l'union européenne n'arrive pas à
avancer parce que chaque état campe dans
sa souveraineté nationale
donc on partage trop peu on devrait
partager beaucoup plus pour le servir on
ne peut appeler des biens communs
européens comme l'éducation l'emploi
l'industrie
toutes ces questions là devraient faire
l'objet maintenant deux copines et
politiques communes aux côtés de
l'ancien conseiller spécial de michel
barnier jean arthuis l'ex ministre de
l'économie a quant à lui évoqué les
enjeux du prochain scrutin et son
importance il est urgent que l'europe
parle enfin
vos citoyens qu'elle dise à quel point
c'est elle qui peut préparer notre
avenir et qui peut nous protéger si
cette europe là qu'il faut construire
que ce soit en matière de changement
climatique de migration ou encore de je
dirais de de régulation des grands
géants du numérique est bien l'europe à
des solutions à nous apporter encore
faut-il pouvoir se saisir de ces
solutions
lors des dernières élections en 2014
seul 42,61 % des citoyens de l'union
européenne s'étaient déplacés aux urnes
une pétition contre les panneaux
numériques elle vient d'être lancé par
le collectif est râpé résistance à
l'agression publicitaire de saint
quentin en yvelines il ya deux jours 25
de ses membres ont mené une action dans
la zone d'activités paris ouest à
maurepas pour dénoncer l'augmentation de
ce type de dispositif qui nuit selon eux
au cadre de vie
pour rappel saint-quentin-en-yvelines
travaille en ce moment sur son règlement
de la publicité intercommunale dans les
grandes orientations votées pas
d'interdiction de ces supports
numériques et mais des restrictions de
plage d'extinction en nocturne fixer la
pétition est disponible sur le site de r
ap économie à présent c'est l'un des
leaders mondiaux de la fabrication à
deux systèmes d'auto l'automatisation
d'infrastructures industrielles
l'entreprise rockwell automation cotée à
la bourse de new york est installé à
voisins le bretonneux depuis une dizaine
d'années michael et demi d'euros et
nicolas landry ont rencontré le
directeur général france nous sommes au
siège social de rockwell automation
france à voisins le bretonneux avec
gilles paco bonjour bonjour d'un
directeur général de la filiale
française de rockwell automation alors
vous êtes pour la onzième fois reconnue
comme l'une des entreprises les plus
éthiques au monde en 2019 par
l'ethisphere institute une structure
spécialisée dans dans l'éthique des
entreprises
en quoi dans votre pratique au quotidien
en france vous êtes éthique dans le
business
effectivement nous sommes très fiers
d'avoir été reconnue à nouveau
comme une réussite est très très éthique
ce que nous faisons pour pour réussir ce
challenge je dirai pas ce que c'est un
challenge quand même tous les jours nous
avons au moment du recrutement déjà une
recrutons des gens qui sont vraiment axé
sur les valeurs des personnes etc
nous avons des cycles de formation qui
sont très importants qui sont réguliers
annuellement tous les effectifs que ce
soit je dirais la secrétaire le
directeur général et le président rhdp
restera nous avons effectivement des
formations sur l'éthique comment se
comporter et c'est aussi au niveau de
nos partenaires de nous avec nos clients
tout l'écosystème donc nous travaillons
de la même façon est ce qu'on se rend
compte c'est que d'être une société
éthique apporte énormément dans le
business sur le long terme ça fidélise
les différents partenaires que vous avez
les partenaires et les clients
alors votre spécialisés et votre se re
spécialité pardon cdc de produire des
systèmes d'automatisation pour les
entreprises industrielles qu'est ce que
c'est
effectivement nous sommes une fac là
c'était l'entreprise la plus importante
au monde qui ne fait que de
contrôle-commande automatisation de
systèmes industriels pour les machines
et pour les procédés donc nous faisons
que ça
alors qu'est ce que c'est c'est au
niveau d'une usine contrôler des
machines contrôlées des systèmes
complets contre les ateliers
donc c'est le contrôle c'est
l'acquisition d'informations c'est la
visualisation pour pouvoir commander ses
machines et ses ateliers et aujourd'hui
maintenant dans le monde de la
digitalisation etc on parle d'internet
des objets industriels est donc là on va
avoir effectivement tout une information
qui va passer tout pendant tout un
paquet d'informations qui a passé de
lusine jusqu'au sommet d'entreprise
lorsqu'on appelle les erp et cetera pour
diffuser ses informations et données in
fine et la bonne information à la bonne
personne au bon moment pour prendre les
bonnes décisions au niveau 2
de la gestion de lusine et donc de la
productivité de l'usiné c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'industrie 4.0 c'est ça alors
on peut couper sa part sous le 4.0 ou en
français on dit l'industrie du futur
qu'est la même chose exactement et donc
effectivement nos solutions répondent
complètement à ce thème et à cette
initiative qui est une initiative dans
pas mal de pays dans le monde qui
effectivement numérisés régénérer un
petit peu l'industrie qui est un secteur
d'activité qui on doit bien en france a
été quand même un petit peu tombé et
donc bas rapporté un petit peu plus de
vitalité à cette industrie
effectivement pu aussi attirer des gens
attirer des talents qui était plus
partis vers d'autres horizons
parce que l'industrie ben vieillit c'est
peut-être ma longpré guillemets et
aujourd'hui avec ces nouvelles fn
numérisation digitalisation etc
on peut ré attiré effectivement des
jeunes des zones jenner etc
depuis environ une dizaine d'années même
plus on parle de désindustrialisation
finalement c'est la solution vous avez
la solution par rapport à cette
désindustrialisation
on pense avoir effectivement partie de
la solution puisque les enjeux
principaux de nos clients et et on peut
on peut les nommer par le time to market
donc ce qu'on appelle avoir des produits
rapidement sur le marché était d'avoir
une utilisation maximale de leur outil
de production
aussi la cyber sécurité donc tout ce qui
est au niveau sécurité donc ça ce sont
effectivement des enjeux prépondérant
pour nos clients avec ses solutions
digitales numériques software que l'on
apporte aujourd'hui on apporte
effectivement des réponses à ces
questions pour nos clients comment vous
fonctionnez en france parce que donc
vous êtes la filiale française de
rockwell automation une entreprise
américaine vous occuper uniquement du
marché français en fait un tout petit
peu plus en france
mais effectivement une société
internationale de 6,7 milliards de
dollars de chiffre d'affaires 24 mille
employés dont le siège est à milwaukee
wisconsin aux états unis ici voisins le
bretonneux vous êtes au siège france
région france c'est à dire la france
métropolitaine mais un peu plus dans la
région france on couvre l'afrique du
nord et l'afrique de l'ouest
quels sont vos clients avec quels types
d'industries vous travaillez or des
jarres cotation souhaitait depuis 200
ans et plus en temps dans l'industrie
donc on a vraiment toujours fait de
l'industrie on travaille avec toutes les
industries
en réalité il n'ya pas vraiment de
l'industrie je dirai qui et qui est
interdite
alors il se trouve qu'en france on a un
métier l'agroalimentaire on travaillait
beaucoup de l'agroalimentaire on va
travailler énormément et que la
pharmacie on va travailler avec
l'automobile où le pneu
on va travailler avec des gens qui
travaillent dans le pétrole donc toutes
les industries et aussi tout
l'écosystème de ces industries donc on
va travailler avec les clients finaux
avec les constructeurs de machines qui
vont vendre dans les mettre dans les
usines avec les intégrateurs systèmes
qui font des projets clés en main pour
les usines on a un réseau de
distribution et de partenaires aussi à
gré qui rejoint d'ailleurs le sujet de
l'éthique probablement abordée vous
l'avez dit 100 ans d'existence
comment vous avez fait ce basculement en
fait dans l'industrie traditionnelle que
l'on peut connaître avec des grosses
machines des grosses industries des
grosses usines et maintenant aujourd'hui
finalement des robots et puis l'homme
qui devient collaboratif et qui
finalement accompagne la machine alors
ces changements viennent essentiellement
des besoins de nos clients encore
automatique a toujours voulu suivre ses
clients donc on essaie vraiment de
prendre qu'elle ait besoin de clients
qu'est ce qu'on peut apporter un client
pour que lui il soit vainqueur sur son
propre marché et donc ces changements
sont venus naturellement avec avec leurs
besoins ce qui est intéressant de noter
c'est que personnellement je suis depuis
plus de 30 ans dans ce métier et les
deux trois dernières années ont été un
accélérateur incroyable vraiment
exponentielle et les changements sont de
plus en plus rapide et donc on passe
effectivement d'un métier qui était de
composants 1 mais c'est qu'ils étaient
solution maintenant un métier
complètement digital j'ai pas qu'aux
merci beaucoup merci à vous directeur
général de rockwell automation france un
entretien réalisé par nicholas dans deux
rives dans la thématique économique
toujours versailles organise demain
mercredi son forum pour l'emploi c'est
de 14 heures à 18 heures à l'hôtel de
ville une soixantaine d'entreprises
présentes pour au final plusieurs
centaines d'offres d'emploi à pourvoir
dans la vente les services ou encore
l'industrie pensez à vous munir de votre
cv car il sera possible de passer des
entretiens sur place
toutes les offres proposées sont d'ores
et déjà à consulter en ligne
de son côté le département des yvelines
recrues de cet été 145 jeunes des
emplois saisonniers pour la 16e édition
d'yveline étudiants seniors des visites
au domicile des personnes âgées
l'objectif développer le lien inter
générale interne générationnel et rompre
l' isolement pour postuler les jeunes
doivent habiter ou étudier dans les
yvelines et avoir au moins 20 ans un
formulaire est à remplir sur le site
internet de la collectivité
nous vous parlions hier de la poule de
houdan mais connaissez-vous sa cousine
la poule faverolles pour la fête de la
francophonie le chef du trianon palace à
versailles frédéric l'arc commun elle
l'a choisi comme plat principal de son
menu spécial reportage de la ferme à
l'assiette et de marylène iapichino et
patrick jacques de dixmude
reconnaissable à sa coupe de cheveux
extravagantes pour une fois ce n'est pas
la poule de houdan qui est mise à
l'honneur mais sa cousine la faverolles
pécoul de plus de deux siècles
[Musique]
c'est une poule t4 est en effet aussi
bien des qualités compte que quelques
des qualités de chair elle et elle est
vraiment très bien qu'elle l'ait
faverolles de l'éleveur eric sanson son
arrivée il ya six mois
elles ont gambadé dans ces grands prés
au milieu des vaches et ont investi ce
poulailler de paris conforte avec portes
automatiques réglé en fonction du lever
au coucher du soleil
à la fin de leur vie on l'est on les
ramène un bon mois dans un dans un box
et elles vont faire un petit peu plus de
là elles vont faire elles vont attendre
un petit peu plus la viande de leurs
demeures royales d'auffargis aux
cuisines du trianon palace versailles
elles ont pas d matos et cds ces
produits qui sont très bien préparées
elles ont pas été agressés sont bien
mûri elles ont eu l'honneur d'être la
race choisie par le chef cuisinier des
lieux frédéric largement pour ce menu
goût de france le 21 mars dernier
c'est la fête de la gastronomie
française dans le monde entier donc on a
un thème tous les ans le thème cette
annonce et produits de proximité est là
justement on a dans les yvelines se
produit à l'exceptionnelle on va pouvoir
mettre en valeur
justement pour le même goût de goutrens
pour sa volaille faverolles aux herbes
de la ferme de la petite up asperges
vertes et maury le chef cuisinier
conserve chaque partie de la foule
on utilise le suprême vraiment donc
farsi les cuisses qui seront en dodine
on récupère le poids et les coeurs pour
les rôtir les mettre en bâtonnets pour
pouvoir rouler dans les cuisses et bien
sûr tout ce qui reste comme carcassonne
les os tout ça on utilise pour
confronter confectionner le jus un
pressage minutieux pour une poule
savoureuse qui mérite qu'on la prenne
avec des pensées
[Musique]
et après à lire le retour dans ce
journal des résultats sport hier on est
aussi bien content de retrouver mélanie
poquet pour sa chronique ou de leur
culture
bonsoir on savait gérer une exposition
des spectacles des ateliers à partir du
5 avril la commanderie à elancourt donne
carte blanche à un artiste david rolland
pour deux semaines d'art et oui david
rolland c'est le chorégraphe de la
compagnie du même nom et il invite à
plusieurs rendez-vous alors le premier
sera à découvrir dans la chapelle de la
commanderie dominique leroy un artiste
plasticien et installera son jardin
d'eau une installation sonore des
végétaux le vendredi 12 avril david
rolland laisse place à l'un de ses
danseurs benoît quant aux jeunes
circassiens pour home
regardez j'ai toujours été fasciné par
la loi de l'effort inverse
vous essayez de rester à la surface de
l'eau
vous couler
quand vous essayez de poulet sauté
en fait ce que tu veux dire
ce qui va un sentiment de kigali entre
accepter que les choses se fassent et
chercher à vouloir tout contrôler
personnellement j'ai l'impression que
les choses elle ça sent l souchez et
chiboub il s'agit en vrac jabbar
fragments parfait alors d'autres
chorégraphes et interprètes de la
compagnie seront présents autour d'un
thème d'une idée construction et
déconstruction et david rolland propres
proposera lui aussi des oeuvres
eh oui deux rendez vous plus précisément
la particularité de ce chorégraphe c'est
de créer de manière participative les
spectateurs deviennent acteurs et
danseurs avec les lecteurs une
chorégraphie collective qui vous
entraîne dans une sorte de balle une
surprise party est une appli manif une
déambulation autoguidés le spectateur
acteur aura un casque sur les oreilles
et suivra les instructions david rolland
n'avait réalisé l'une dans le quartier
17 mar d'elancourt en 2017 sont les
images que l'on voit c'était une
découverte artistique mais aussi
historique et cette fois encore il
s'inspire du lieu la commanderie ce qui
m'a inspiré dans dans ce lieu c'est bon
à la fois bien sûr son histoire les
templiers
le fait que ça devienne une ferme puis
un lieu de résidence pour des
plasticiens et puis ce qui s'y fait
aujourd'hui grâce à ces quatre
départements missionnés sur la danse
les itinéraires poétique la science et
les arts visuels
alors david rolland a carte blanche
jusqu'au 22 avril et comme vous en avez
l'habitude pour tout savoir et ne rien
rater le programme est disponible sur le
site kiosque points ce qui prime
merci mélanie retour pour le coup de
coeur retour également tout à l'heure
aux manettes de votre émission le 7-8
culture et vous reviendrez notamment sur
la dixième édition de l'ombre d'un coup
le festival international du film court
qui se tenait ce week-end à jouy en
josas et dont tv 78 étaient partenaires
une quarantaine de films projetés sur
deux jours de compétition et 17 prix ont
été remis le grand prix du public
revient à troc mort de martin darondeau
à l'issue d'un braquage de croque-mort
se retrouvent dépossédés du cercueil et
du corps dont il avait la charge pour
trouver à leur place le butin des
malfaiteurs et le prix du public pour
les jouvencelles de delphine corps avec
notamment annie cordy lauréate du prix
d'interprétation féminine
une histoire d'amitié qui se nouent au
sein d'une maison de retraite palmarès
complet à retrouver sur la page facebook
du
festival et on va terminer justement ce
journal sur une touche festive avec mon
invité christian etienne bonsoir en soit
vous êtes le vice-président du cercle
celtique 16 havel alors il organise son
traditionnel fest-noz du printemps c'est
ce samedi à la merise attrape c'est à
partir de 20h alors le cercle celtique
sésame elle existe depuis 1972 et il a
pour mission de promouvoir la culture
bretonne c'est ça tout à fait hors vous
voir la culture bretonne à travers la
danse et la musique principalement mais
aussi de faire connaître la langue
bretonne à travers les champs et voilà
c'est notre mission mais on a un
éventail d'activités qui va au delà de
2d ce cas que sur la noce bretonne une
dette de création à censier 1972 midi et
tout à l'heure que c'était l'association
culturelle la plus ancienne à saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est l'association des plaisanciers de
51 ans et de trappe alors dans
l'émission dans les actions ou vous
développer notamment pour participer à
plusieurs événements et notamment au
championnat national de danses bretonnes
c'est ça chaque année ce qui t'a fait
alors pas tous les ans ou tous les deux
ans parce qu'on essaye de faire d' avoir
d'autres buts
de temps en temps et là on va participer
au trail des havanes qui a lieu tous les
ans mais là nous on y participent tous
les deux ans et cette année en histoire
des participations également au festival
interceltique de lorient alors il ya un
nouveau projet aussi cette année une
participation aux européennes c'est un
grand festival européen du folklore qui
va se dérouler en allemagne tout avec
qui se déroulera cette année en
allemagne et l'année dernière il s'est
déroulé quelques danseurs du cercle sont
allés au portugal est ce que la culture
bretonne est bien établie en ile de
france dans les yvelines est ce qu'il y
a beaucoup de représentants de cette
culture bretonne il ya beaucoup de
représentants il ya des cercles
rambouillet apprécié pour les yvelines
et dans tous les départements de l'île
de france est depuis 1996 vous organisez
donc ce fest-noz du printemps attrape un
terme que l'on entend souvent le
fest-noz qu'est ce que ça signifie le
fest-noz quelle est sa signification
également son avenir fait de nuit
d'accord donc une fête de lui alors
c'est de la danse bretonne voilà c'est
un bal breton est animé par des groupes
de chants et de danses
le grêlé ce camp qui est du champ de
réponse vous avez deux personnes qui
chantent hausse en répondant c'est une
vraie tradition bretonne
vous avez donc la musique traditionnelle
avec le biniou bombarde et
depuis des années soixante dix avec la
venue d'alain stivell la musique s'est
diversifiée avec les instruments
modernes que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
donc les guitares électriques batteries
le synthétiseur
voilà donc ces on peut avoir des cuivres
aussi qu'on en aura fait mais c'est pas
que pour les bretons ça s'adresse à tout
le monde le l'idée c'est que ce soit un
moment festif un moment de partage alors
que c'est à dire que les faisceaux ont
été classés au patrimoine immatériel de
la culture française et bretonne du fait
que ce soit une fête
intergénérationnelle où tout le monde
peut venir s'amuser s'est lancée voilà
c'est le but c'est de s'amuser et toutes
les générations sont représentées ce
soir là on fait toujours au retour des
beaux jours le fest-noz ou un
traditionnellement voilà on a eu nos
date qui a été fixée au mois de mars
quoi et on l'a appelé le faisceau de
printemps est-ce que depuis 1996 c'est
toujours un rendez vous qui attire
chaque année elle à chaque année il ya
une attente et une attente il ya même
une demande de la part des groupes qui
viennent de bretagne
parce que pour eux c'est une référence
pour leur carrière de venir au fait
c'est le fascine de trappes
alors dites-nous cette année qu'est ce
que vous avez prévu pour pour cette
édition alors c'est léo qui va être le
leader
venir à trappes passera la soirée avec
nous et vient de bretagne et qui était
fort mais vu que deux chanteuses aidé
plusieurs musiciens qui se sont
rencontrés et puis un jour ils ont
décidé de travailler ensemble et ça fait
plusieurs années qu'ils travaillent
ensemble qu'ils égrène les fest-noz en
région parisienne et en bretagne
d'autres groupes à la pige ailleurs si
on veut s'entraîner à la danse bretonne
initiations gratuites qui est prévue ce
jeudi à 20 heures c'est au gymnase de
l'école paul langevin à trappe placée là
où on travaillait actuellement
donc il y aura une initiation à la danse
bretonne pour ceux qui le souhaitent
pour que si vous le venir festoyer qui
ne soigne pas perdu mais de toute façon
même au fest-noz rentrer dans les rondes
et vous est pris au jeu et voilà ça se
fait naître tout à fait naturellement
une expo photo ci qui est proposée cette
année avec bolt photo ira peut-être
aussi quelques costumes de disposer pour
montrer le travail que nous fournissons
parce que les costumes sont faits en
partie par les membres du groupe et faut
savoir que c'est un travail de broderie
principalement et les causes humaines
dans lequel on fait des représentations
en france et à l'étranger
une question pratique est ce qu il faut
réserver à l avance on peut venir
directement sur place allaient la chose
le risque nous permet de ne pas faire de
trop de possibilités de réservation mais
on peut venir sans problème sans
réservation et je précise tarif de 10
euros gratuit pour les enfants de moins
de 12 ans il ya aussi des tarifs de
groupe
les enfants accompagnés de parents
accompagnés d'un parent c'est important
de le préciser le fest-noz du printemps
qui est donc au programme ce samedi 30
mars à la merise attrape c'est à partir
de 20 heures et s'est organisée par le
cercle celtique assez havel merci
christian etienne d'être massée sur une
place au vice président de cette
association
voilà c'est la fin du set 8 journal
merci de votre fidélité cette interview
et et tous les reportages de cette
édition a retrouvé bien sûr sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]